I said I was going to do something crazy at
50K.
Hopefully that lived up to your expectations.
HUGE, huge, huge thank you to you guys.
I know I talked a lot about this on Twitter,
but big thank you to everybody who's supported
me.
Fifty K is just such a huge milestone.
I know it's kind of cliche for YouTubers to
thank their audience when they reach milestones.
I can't do a face reveal because you guys
already know what you look like, but hopefully
this was entertaining for you.
I know a lot of people wanted to see me shave
my beard for some reason.
I don't know what the whole fascination with
that is, but everybody really wants me to
shave my beard so here, I'm gonna make you
guys a deal.
If we can hit 100,000 subscribers, that is
twice what we have now by the end of the year,
I'm gonna go through with it and shave my
beard in a video.
Just a couple updates on things going on around
the channel.
I know you guys have been waiting and waiting
for the new Al Dente Creepypasta.
I've got good news for the people who subscribed
to see that.
There is a new Al Dente Creepypasta coming
very very soon.
I think it's gonna be the best one yet,a nd
I've got some exciting collaborations lined
up for future episodes.
It should come as no surprise that I'm also
working on more Things You Missed, and we've
gotten to the point where the movies that
I talked about in the first couple episodes
of Things You Missed are now about to come
out so if you want to see me talk about those
movies again when they come out, let me know
down in the comments.
And just in general, let me know what kind
of stuff you guys like to see.
I've been experimenting a lot on the channel
and I want to make stuff that I like making
and you guys like watching.
The best way for me to do that is for me to
know what you guys like watching.
So head down in the comments and give me some
suggestions.
The next Deadstream is going to be August
27th.
It's gonna be at the same time, it's 2PM pacific,
that 5PM eastern, 10PM British Summer Time.
So be sure to join us then.
So that just about wraps things up.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, and remember, 100,000
before New Years Day and I chop off the beard.
You're also gonna want to ring that death
bell for notifications.
If you subscribe and you don't hit that little
bell next to the subscribe button, then it
doesn't do anything for you.
You have to hit the bell otherwise you're
not going to get my videos for some reason.
Thank you again for all the support.
Thank you again for 50,000 subscribers.
That number just still doesn't even make sense
to me.
I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.